[Music]
hello welcome back to the road mm my
name is Caleb Denby and as always I will
be your driver on this journey today I
wanted to go over what is pretty much
the only major chess tournament
happening of course all in person over
the board tournaments are currently
postponed but Magnus Carlsen on chess 24
has actually set up a super tournament
online so I've been having a lot of fun
following those games and I picked a few
interesting ones for us to check out
tonight so why don't we just jump into
it the first game that I want to look at
today is between Magnus Carlsen and
Alireza Perugia Magnus of course was
recently defeated by firoozeh in an
online match and so Magnus gave him an
invite to this tournament and looked to
crush him and Magnus's own words he
wanted to crush Perugia he did end up
winning their four game match I believe
with two wins one loss and a draw so you
know kind of kind of crushed him I don't
know but this game that I wanted to look
at starts with d4 and after Knight f6 we
have c4 e6 now Knight f3
of course this move order by a white
kind of avoids the nimzo-indian
by not developing this bishop just yet
and so there are a couple approaches for
black to take at this point you can just
go for normal Queens gambit declined
structures or you can go for your crazy
stuff like the BOGO or things like the
benoni
do whatever you want here in the game
Perugia starts with d5 going for normal
Queens gambit structures but after
Knight c3 now Jie instead of just
playing normal Queens gambit type most
went for the rigo's in there goes in is
a personal favorite of mine recently and
I wanted to see how version handled this
position and how Magnus went about
trying to win so now there are a lot of
lines against there it goes and but and
in classic Magnus Carlsen style he kind
of just develops his pieces simply and
tries to play a game of chess this is
what Magnus is pretty much known for
doesn't do crazy opening preparation
while I mean of course they they all do
crazy opening prep but he doesn't really
try to win the game in the opening he
allows his opponent to play chess with
him and looks for mistakes along the way
so Magnus chose a pretty simple line C
takes d5 he takes d5 and then simply
Bishop f4 and perhaps this isn't quite
as testing as normal lines with Bishop
g5 but with Bishop f4 Magnus gets the
bishop out to a perfectly active square
and is just looking to play chess key
pieces on the board and keep the game
going
firoozeh went ahead and castled
perfectly fine and now white played III
and now I wanted you guys to step into a
Larissa ferocious shoes and try to come
up with a move here there are some
problems you still need to figure out
and with black here for example your
king side is developed but you have not
developed any of these pieces on the
Queen side so this is really your task
in the opening your opponent has not
really played deep deep theory or
anything they just developed their
pieces and now you need to come up with
a strategy for developing your own
pieces picking which squares you want to
put your pieces on and how you want to
organize them to form a plan and I think
this is really the moment where version
has to decide this you know you played
all the normal and rigo's and moves he
got his Bishop to b4 he got his Knight
to f6 and a Castle kingside now he has
to decide which of the plans he really
wants to go for here so why don't you
guys at home try and come up with a
logical plan so you develop the pieces
around so I won't give you too much more
than that to start with and then I'll
talk a little bit about the various
plants that's how you could in fact play
here okay so let's see what you guys can
come up with on this one
I'm bringing back the the trusty spray
haven't had one of these during a class
in a while
storm GD says when when is your only
option
Jimmy she she comes up with the move
Bishop f5 that's a pretty reasonable
move but it's not really a plan for the
rest of your development I want to to
kind of see your your plan for the rest
of your pieces that's the way you should
approach the opening in serious games of
chess like over the board games you want
to come up with a plan for all your
pieces before you kind of just start
moving them out of course the exception
to this is when you're not sure where
you want a piece yet that can also
happen but what I mean by that is not so
much you know you just don't know what
to do
but you want to keep your options open
for certain pieces that can happen as
well okay there are a couple people
saying Bishop f5 something simple has
given a few options
he likes c6 he likes turkey eight he
likes probably knight c6 is 20 many said
Knight f6 and in Bishop f5 and these are
pretty reasonable options Bishop g4 has
now been suggested b6 and Bishop a6 has
been suggested but so far the majority
of people are saying moves like Bishop
f5 it moves like c6 and these are in
fact perfectly fine moves what I wanted
to talk about though is it's kind of the
plan for development here you want to
kind of take stock of your position and
come up with what you're doing in the
middle game so these are nice developing
moves but you'll see we we're kind of
scattered in the chat right now kind of
scattered yeah no really coherent idea
of what we want to do thank you for the
two dollars Leia unfortunately no games
in this game isn't even in tonight's
lecture but I will try and get one for
you
in the next week's lecture okay and
someone has suggested 94 as well so what
do I mean by finding a plan for the
pieces well it's well and good to put
the bishop on g5 and to put the knight
on c6 but you want to actually be doing
something with these pieces in the game
Peruggia actually did play bishop at
five and it's true that this move is
totally fine and
one of the best moves but I actually
prefer the move c5 here this is a move
that nobody in the chat actually
suggested it's a common break and there
it goes in and why I like it is it kind
of gives black some sense of direction
here gives you an idea of what you want
to do with your pieces for example if Y
it simply develops let's say I move like
Bishop eat to well we can simply play a
move like knight c6
and now all of our pieces are in fact
working kind of together if you want to
support this plane even further let's
say white castles you can even bring
this Bishop out to e6 and support your
d5 pawn for an eventual D takes e5 which
white would likely play at some moment
and in fact I took a look at the
database here and D takes e5 was really
the most common move played against c5
but now this really does give blacks
some direction you want to respond to
this with Queen a5 and you're piling up
on this night and hoping to recapture
this pawn it eventually and the game
might continue Bishop e5 Knight ft-7
hitting this Bishop and then the game I
took a look at between whooshing sheep
and someone named Fred key I've never
heard of this player but he seemed to be
good enough a3 was played Knight takes
e5 a takes b4 and I takes f3 she takes
f3 and Queen takes b4 and now black
really does have some sense of what he's
doing he's gonna play knight c6 hitting
this Queen and develop this Bishop out
to e6 and it's gonna be a pretty even
game so I like the move c5 for black now
I want to do a lot of specifics there
but the general rule I'm trying to
follow here is to come up with some kind
of plan for your pieces before just
simply developing them you want your
pieces to work together other moves that
were suggested that I did like 94 is
another good way to go about continuing
this position here you pile up on c3 you
can continue with c5 and once again
bring your pieces out to work in tandem
with each other okay a quick correction
correction I've been told that
fortuitous fire did in fact suggest c5
don't want to take away fortuitous
buyers credit but it wasn't the most
common
just didn't by any means but okay bishop
i-5 was played in the game it's not as
though this is a bad move but I do like
moves that have a bit more sense of
direction in fact though this Bishop is
active enough that we'll see that Magnus
eventually drives it back to e6 anyways
Queen d3 was played in the game and this
is why I kind of liked the immediate c5
in fact now this bishops a little bit
attacked and we don't really have this
option of playing Queen a5 directly if
we play C 5 now well what happens let me
actually check I think actually D take C
5 and now if you go for Queen a5 you're
gonna run into some Bishop d6 ideas and
the spawns gonna be a little bit tougher
to to get a hold of so instead knight c6
and it's once again not as the black is
doing much wrong here black has all the
pieces out and is totally developed but
due to the manner in which he developed
his pieces this pawn is kind of awkward
stuck on c7 and in fact all of the
queenside pawns are slightly awkward
here you'll see Magnus actually has
pressure on c7 this pawn is defended
though he has pressure on d5 once again
the pawn is defended though and he has
pressure on b7 and with these three
pawns to kind of keep track of we'll see
that's where firuze just started going a
little bit wrong so I wouldn't say white
is much better in this position if he's
even better at all but I would say it's
a lot more comfortable to play with the
white pieces here and that's what Magnus
is really good at doing so that's why in
the opening I like coming up with these
plans to try and solve my problems
before just simply developing my my
pieces here so because black has some
problems here that's why I I really
think Magnus did a good job in this
opening ok
a little bit of text yes a little bit of
text so 96 does defend this Bishop for
the moment now Magnus took the time out
of his busy schedule to attack this
Bishop and force it to a less active
square on Bishop e6
that's why Bishop f5 was probably in
fact a better developing square than e
six for this Bishop it's active enough
that Magnus felt the need to push it
back anyways now the Bishop's been
pushed back in this Bishop can go on
this most natural diagonal here from d3
and then once again this is where
firoozeh went for a slightly strange
looking plan and I think it's this plan
that ends up losing the game for him he
plays a pretty weird-looking move a 5
now why would a larysa play the move a 5
here well what he's doing is trying to
get a little bit of a stronghold here on
the beef or a square he wants to use b4
for the rest of his pieces in order to
kind of launch some attacks on the Queen
side but we'll see that this a f5 move
is the one weakness that kind of led
Magnus to be able to win the game now
that's not to say Magnus is winning here
or anything but it's these you know step
by step weaknesses that firuze is making
that Magnus eventually takes advantage
of so you always really do want to be
wary when pushing pawns like this of the
squares and of course leaves behind in
this case the b5 square ended up being
really critical to this game so the game
continued with Magnus simply castling
you know just because something creates
a weakness doesn't mean you have to
immediately take advantage of it now
there are some threats of Knight b5 here
hitting c7 so frisia went for Knight h5
picking off this Bishop Bishop g3 Knight
takes H takes and now Bishop e7 and I
think this may actually be the move that
gives Magnus a pretty serious advantage
here of course if white were to capture
on b7 black has a few options here there
are going to be problems along this B
file to come immediately though black of
course
has to deal with this night this was the
point though of the a five move giving
this night this beef Foursquare hitting
this Bishop and now h4 is going to hang
and there are still rook b8 ideas on
this be to square so can't take
immediately but Magnus simple chess just
plays Knight f3 and from here we go into
a rather forcing line that's really
shows that that Magnus is is just gonna
have the upper hand in this game so I
wanted to back up here
perhaps the move that should have been
played is already the slightly weird 97
this is actually what I found in my
analysis with the computer self this is
really the only way I could find for
blacks to kind of stick in this game on
an even playing field
97 looks very very strange the idea is
you just free up this pawns mobility a
little bit without committing to Bishop
e7 just yet so the game might continue
with a 3 its Bishop could hop back to d6
now we do have this revered idea again
some night b5 challenges this Bishop but
now Knight c8 and this is how black is
kind of holding everything together with
this strange-looking night on c8 it all
is going to be ok Knight f5 could be
played Bishop e7 takes takes maybe
Knight back to c3 and a simple c6 move
and at the end of the day black held
together these Queen side pawns for the
moment and should be doing just fine so
that's the weird 97 is really the only
thing I could find for black because
after Bishop e7 will see simply Knight
back to f3 now there are pretty serious
threats on b7 so night before is played
now this Bishop drives back to e2 and
firoozeh
does in fact go for this move c5
unfortunately though now after a 3 Ally
Reza is pretty much committed to making
significant weaknesses in his structure
a through of course attacks this Knight
and if the knight moves then b7 will
fall
so after c5 a 3 C 4 is more or less
forced to kick the Queen away Queen D
one night a6 and now I challenge you
to find the best move for white here the
white that solidifies a very distinct
advantage a advantage that Magnus went
onto you went on to use to win the game
white to move and get a huge positional
edge the topic tonight is the Magnus
Carlsen Invitational
so not just Magnus Carlson's games but
he's currently running an invitational
tournament on chest 24 with some of the
world's strongest players and so we're
taking a look at some games from that
tournament
so white to move and get an advantage
see what you guys can find here
and we have suddenly three answers in
the chat ah and one person who had
apparently seen the game life so the
three people in the chat all want to
play the movie four and this is a good
idea this is a really common way to
break down this structure here we have a
lot of people saying e4 yeah so a common
way to challenge this push on the wing
it doesn't challenge the center any
longer and so it kind of frees up white
to play in the center a bit more the
problem here is I think black would
simply capture this pawn and after we
take back we're allowing perhaps say a
critical move here b5 if you're allowing
black to gain control of this be five
square you might be running into a
little bit of trouble for example of b4
+ c3 ever come on the board then you're
really gonna be in for it and so the
correct way to challenge these pawns is
not actually attacking the base of the
pawn chain with efore but rather
attacking the head of the pawn chain
with the move B 3 as was played in the
game and this move gives white a pretty
clear advantage 95 was also suggested
but I I don't think this is quite quite
right here it's not quite fast enough it
doesn't prove the knight quite nicely
but you know moves like Knight c7 and b5
might end up coming on the board anyways
note that if you were to play move like
a 4 here you're also giving up some
squares like Bishop b4 that you have to
be a little bit wary of so the move here
is b3 this is the move to give white the
huge advantage that he had in the game
now what's the big deal if we take this
pawn the problem is Queen takes b3 and
how are you defending b7 it is really
not so easy moves like Queen d7 are
gonna run into various tactics like 95
for example and this pawn would fall if
you come to c7 for example well then
Knight takes D 7 or a knight takes d5
rather is gonna be a problem
winning the pawn here if rugby eights
well maybe you hold on to the pawn
for the moment but moves like queen b5
are already going to be putting a lot of
pressure on your center expect to see
these rooks eventually come over it was
like night a 4 and Knight c5 are going
to come and if it's not an immediate
pawn it's going to be a huge advantage
the other big problem is you can't
really bring this knight back into the
game unless you want to drop a 5 so
really really difficult stuff here for
black to deal with it was like 95 as
well and it's it's just going to be near
impossible for black to hold everything
together
also note that b7 there is gonna be a
permanent weakness backwards pawn so
instead of taking on b3 black went for
night c7 immediately and this is perhaps
a little bit of a better try now of
course the move is going to be B takes
e4 and D takes e4 and now wait to move
here again there are some there are
actually a few options but I like the
move Magnus played the best because it
really keeps in line with the strategy
we've been talking about so far so wait
to move again see what you can find
what can you find
looked a little peaceful says fortuitous
fire not so much it makes some pretty
serious threats
okay so Tiago once again says the movie
four and it's true that efore is one of
the best moves here maybe even the best
move just expanding in the center but
it's not really the way magnus carlsen
always plays chess Magnus
kind of has found a target and he really
committed to trying to take this pawn
and kind of crushing his opponent
however I'm not going to take away any
points for jesting efore efore is a very
good move but it does allow b5 and now
all of a sudden the game is gonna be a
little bit more double-edged it's gonna
be double edged in White's favor because
of this massive Center but black isn't
playing for nothing anymore the move
that Magnus played I think is
practically the best move even if it's
not theoretically the best move that
move of course is a four not Queen a4
Queen afford doesn't really get the job
done
maybe maybe Queen f4 is good actually
but you do have to be a little bit
careful of some things for example maybe
some p5 sacrifice tonight takes b5
indirect b8 and perhaps black is is
finding some counter play from from the
depths of his position but a4 locks all
of that down now b5 is never going to be
playable because of a takes b5 or even
Knight takes b5 and the be father
remains closed and white would go up
upon it for pretty much nothing so I
like this move a for I think practically
it's a really great idea just
permanently fixing this pawn on c4 as a
weakness and now all that's left for
Magnus is to clean up this pawn so if
Bishop b4 was played like I said a 4
does give up this square now Queen c2
defends the night yeah perhaps
rook c1 was a better way of defending
the knight just because of the specifics
we'll take a look at it so Queen c2
black immediately captured on c3 but now
is really his opportunity he has just
enough time to defend his pawn with
moves like rook c8 now let's for example
play rook c1 trying to pile up well now
perhaps
it's 95 comes after the pawn Bishop
takes Queen takes Knight d5 and we might
be pushing to c3 just in time here just
in time let's compare that within the
game
Bishop takes c3 Queen takes no 95 the
Queen comes over to a3
this jerk still comes to c8 but Rick FC
one this night comes to b4 and Magnus
now simply doubles on the C file and
this is the problem for Rajah this this
weakness on c4 has become the story of
the entire game white didn't really
create any weaknesses with his opening
and black but the one weakness on c4 it
turns out it's just gonna be enough for
Magnus here he's going to win this pawn
and then go on to win the game 95 was
played now rook back to see one night
before is repeating but 95 is Magnus's
improvement upon the position c3 was
played trying to sneak this pawn through
note that taking here might be a little
bit of a mistake because night c2 is a
playable move and things get a little
bit crazy here but this Fork is in fact
going to win an exchange so little bit
of caution is required
luckily Magnus has a little bit of
caution plays the move Knight d3 now
sorry Queen b6 was Ali Reza's choice and
now simply rook a b1 is a mistake
you cannot play like this so I'll give
you this position white to move and get
a winning advantage here white to move
and get a winning advantage and then
we're gonna take a look and see why York
a 2 B 1 is in fact incorrect
white to move and get a winning
advantage will rather keep his winning
advantage I should say
I in fact can believe that Lawrence
Trent thought black was better in this
position and I can also believe that's
Alexander Grisham proved him wrong for
those of you unaware chess 24 has quite
the commentary team on this tournament
including famous famous people such as
Peter Svidler Alexander Brescia Lawrence
Trent's I believe Tanya sash dev is
actually giving commentary as well okay
everybody in the chat seems to have it
the move is of course Nate c5 you just
block off this entire file and I'll see
to is the only try to keep the pawn but
Bishop d3 is going to be enough for
white you're going to collect this pawn
without any further delay once again
rook takes c3 actually does fail tonight
c2 picking up this exchange now the move
in the game rook a b1 does seem to be
pretty good here pinning this Knight but
black has an amazing resource here to in
fact take the advantage much less
equalized so find the move for black to
take the advantage here what can you do
oh sorry
I'll be very impressed if you guys can
find this one it's a pretty tactical
sequence that takes advantage of the
momentary awkwardness of the white
pieces White's pieces just ended up a
little bit loose in this position so if
you can find a way let's make use of be
loose pieces in this case it's gonna be
this bishop in this Knight that are
loose find a way to take advantage of
the loose pieces here and then the
answer is yours okay everybody's
suggesting Knight see - that's not gonna
be the one not gonna be the one Queen
takes f8 Andric takes p6 wins the floor
up little too clever little too clever
so a couple people have suggested the
correct first move and that move is of
course c2 pushing this pawn all the way
to c2 now it looks like rook b2 is gonna
be enough we're gonna take p4 next turn
win this pawn then we're gonna win this
pawn they're gonna be up all the puns
then we're gonna win the game but black
has to find the only move here
Queen a6 so well done to you if you
found the correct first move if you
found the correct second move even more
well done to you and after Bishop f1 if
you found the only move here Bishop c4
then kudos to you you are better than
Magnus Carlsen at this one specific
tactic and of course now things are just
slightly too awkward for white with all
of these pieces you can play Knight
takes b4 but black will simply recapture
Queen takes b4 and now Bishop takes f1
is going to be the problem here you
cannot recapture this piece due to this
C pawn so black really makes you know
use of all the things hanging in the
balance for a single turn tactically
everything worked out for him you know
the the knight was just loose enough the
bishop was just loose enough and then
the pawn was just far enough for the
tactics to work out here so this was in
fact missed by both players
understandably it's it's a pretty weird
tactic where you have to find a series
of only moves but well done do you guys
at home if you manage to to find that
one Rouge it did not instead choosing
the play Bishop f5 this move does attack
this night but now simply rook b3
is good enough to win the game before
Magnus Bishop takes and Bishop takes was
played of course this night is pinned
for the moment now c2 but in this case
Magnus can simply capture on c2
and he does now Magnus upon up with a
crushing central advantage went on to
win this game let's check out how he did
it
rook takes Bishop takes he brings the
bishop out to f5 brings his pieces to
pretty natural squares this Bishop is
gonna drop back either to e2 or f3 and
keep an eye on this Queen side oops I
skip to the end
let's not do that hopefully so Bishop f5
and we are here Queen B - rook c3 this
bishop does drop back to e2 now Queen a5
rebecc-- to c1 bishop up to b5
Magnus puts all his pieces on really
natural squares the rook on the only
open file the bishop on a square where
it's defended blockading black's pawn
and now after rook c8 we saw a trade
this queen comes to d2 queen a five and
now Magnus starts to get these pawns
pushing with the move f3 King f2 Queen
d3 and now simply e4 and this game is
well in Magnus's hands and now after the
move Queen e6 here Magnus got a little
fancy kind of unnecessarily he plays the
move Queen seed for allowing black to
take on e4 but now simply Queen takes f7
and the black king is in fact just dying
in this position Queen f6 threatens
mates and defends this pawn king age 7
Queen e5 was played now Queen c2 check
Magnus simply tuxes King onto h2 where
it is going to be safe night c2 and now
Magnus finds the mate with Bishop c4 no
way to really stop the the checkmate
here for example Queen takes d4 is
Bishop g8 check Bishop f7 Queen g8 and
Queen g6
with a checkmate and that is the game so
this was a really impressive game I
think by it by Magnus Carlsen and it
shows how you know subtle decisions you
make
early on can really impact the rest of
the game so once again I wanted to take
a look back at this move after e3 the
move ali reza played is perhaps even the
best move in the position the Bishop f5
and getting the bishop to the most
active square but maybe it's worth
considering moves such as c5 moves the
give your pieces more of a purpose
earlier on so that you don't kind of
fall in to these various problems in the
opening and then especially later on I
really don't like this move a5 you know
it seems like a perfectly fine move but
it commits to to so much in fact instead
maybe even a move like 94 could be
played with ideas of expanding on the
kingside instead moves that play towards
a more solid plan
whereas this play on the queenside just
ended up going in Magnus's favor alright
any questions on this game well I'm
doing this review here just for example
some Kings side play here I went through
that really fast it was a bit of a
sideline that I had too much fun with
but ok any any questions so of course a5
and then the theme of this game is
Magnus Potts a weakness prevents all
counter play and eventually execute on
the weakness and and goes up upon to win
the game that's kind of the classic
Magnus Carlsen game no counter play just
suffering ok with that in mind why don't
we just move on to this game between
Hikaru Nakamura and Anish Giri of course
this is a game from the same tournament
just to explain the format of this
tournament a little bit it's kind of a
series of matches between these super
GM's
they're playing like series of four
games I believe with a tiebreaker game
of between and some weird scoring system
that I don't understand but I don't have
to understand it so this game like I
said between Nakamura and Garry starts
with d4 again we have Knight f6 c4 g6
Knight f3 Bishop g7 III and black
castles so what we have here is an H
Garry playing a Kings Indian defense
type of
position and white taking a slightly
more conservative conservative approach
not pushing too far in the center
directly just developing the pieces and
fighting through some of these dark
squares white now plays Bishop e2 black
plays c5 and now white does in fact take
this extra central space with the move
d5 and this is now a type of benoni
style of structure here white has this
extra or this extra space with this pawn
on d5 in this case he's left this pawn
on e3 or defends some dark squares like
d4 and f4 not yet committing to the e4
square where sometimes it can come under
fire and it's going to be a Benoni type
of position so the players naturally
switch to some Benoni type of plans
black plays d6 white castles now we have
e 6 Knight c3 he takes d5 NC takes d5
and we are squarely within the Benoni of
course in the benoni it's usually a good
idea for black to try to trade off one
set of minor pieces at least one set of
minor pieces since he has so little
space it's just a little bit more
comfortable for him if he does get rid
of one set so that's why the move Bishop
g4 came on the board here after the move
Knight d2 this is not actually the most
common way for white to play generally
here there are quite a few games in the
database white plays the move h3 black
takes and white takes and we have this
position with the night for the bishop
off the board now 92 is actually an
attempt at an improvement on this line
in this case we're actually going to
favor the white knight to the white
Bishop here this Bishop does tend to get
a little bit stuck behind the white pawn
Shane if we're not careful
whereas this knight can jump into c4 and
attack some really key dark squares so
in this case the knight is simply a
better minor piece than the bishop for
white so why doesn't everybody play like
this I hear you asking well why don't we
check it out black simply plays Bishop
take c2 Queen takes e to is the natural
follow-up once again just preparing to
bring this night out and now black
actually plays a really great move here
Knight a 6
of course there are a couple ways to
develop this night in the benoni night
bd7 is one going for squares like e5 or
potentially even b6 sometimes but mainly
in the e5 square night a six is another
way of developing of course this Knight
doesn't intend to stay on a6 it
sometimes comes out to be four but more
often steps back to c7 where it
pressures some really key squares in the
white camp white plate the most natural
move here rip d1 simply defending this
pawn however it is black to move and
actually get a pretty nice advantage in
this opening and this is why the move 92
does not see as much play I'm willing
willing to wager here because black has
this line that gives a little bit of an
edge so best of luck to you see if you
can find the line here see if you can
find the line
the chat seems to have been sidetracked
on whether or not I'm qualified to teach
this class I'm terrified what if they
decide I'm not
okay so I don't know if the chat is
going to come up with the moves here of
course the idea for black is to actually
get the key break b5 in this is the
reason this line isn't played so much
because due to the placement of the
white pieces black has a tactical
strategy to come up with a way to play
this move b5 and if black achieves b5 so
early on in the Benoni it's it's almost
always going to be good for him this
extra queenside space really comes in
handy and helps activate the black
pieces so tactically how does it work
well it starts with the move Knight c7
now Knight c7 of course makes a threat a
threat to capture this pawn in theory
you could ignore this threat with a move
like a four and after takes takes takes
play a move like Knight c4 but after now
night before you do get the pawn back
but the Black Knight is still active in
with these pawns off the board it's
really not going to be good for white
this bishop is going to be the story of
the game on this long diagonal so Knight
takes d5 is in fact a threat worth
responding to well how do you respond to
it generally the move efore should be
played so let's say you play e4 well now
all of a sudden you might get hit with
the move rook e8 rook e8 of course is
simply renewing this threat on d5 using
this pin on the e pawn so let's say rook
e8 gets played and the Queen comes to d3
defending once again well now we have
finally done it the tactics work out and
black achieves this move b5 tactically
this is in fact working of course if
white captures this pawn you're going to
get met with the Knight takes d5 between
takes b5 and Knight takes e4 and with
the e4 pawn off the board this is going
to be very very good for black rook b8
is coming these pieces are working
together black controls the e-file
and white is in fact simply
underdeveloped black might even be
winning in this line
quite simply so the move 97 was in fact
the correct way to start here hitting
this eve hitting this d5 pawn and
tactically achieving this break with b5
the moral of the story here is once
again you can't really autopilot in the
openings you have to always be on the
lookout for these these opportunities to
really take take the lead here and
expand with your plans as as early and
as quickly as possible so 97 would have
been nice
rookie eight instead came on the board
and likely Geary had some very very
similar ideas and he simply started with
with rocky 8 instead the problem though
is now after the move Knight c4 we can't
really do the same thing that the same
line as we just looked at because now if
you play the move Knight c7 this pawn is
defended for the moment and white simply
has time to play this move a four and
slow down the b5 break so and once again
just just to restate you cannot play
Knight c4 here because then the move b5
kick kicks the night away just to
restate what I'm talking about
so Ricky eight night c4 was in fact
played now black does get to trade off
one more set of pieces with the move 94
no comfortable way to really avoid this
trade it was like 95 just don't make so
much sense this nights gonna get kicked
away anyways for example night before it
could come and moves like a a6 are on
the cards for black so k94 white does in
fact capture and rook takes and now a4
is White's idea to stop this break with
b5 now Geary is black in this position
hopefully you can see his name up there
Knight c7 was played once again aiming
for d5 and aiming for the b5 break but
now unfortunately for black white has
really attained a pretty nice grip on
the position with the way that the
opening went black is not so easily
going to be getting this break with b5
white has achieved a very strong knight
on c4 and it's Knight that can't really
be kicked away so I think the opening
battle really went in Nakamura's favor
here he got this slightly more favorable
trade of the LightSquared Bishop and
black missed his opportunity to take
advantage of it by getting this b5 break
in
why is a four here better than in the
previous game you showed us well it's a
kind of different positions but a four
was actually a great move in the
previous game as as well and that's part
of how magnus carlsen won that game at
the right moment at the right moment but
here the idea is this is how black wants
to attain counter play by kicking this
night away and expanding on the
queenside and I for simply stops it so
now with this grip on the position the
black pieces are kind of doomed to just
shuffling around and waiting for white
do something and with that white really
does have the advantage
what is going to be focused now on
preventing white from breaking through
rather than seeking his own play on the
queenside
so the game did continue with Bishop d2
Queen d7 and now Queen d3 comes on the
board this rooks attacks black in in
this game rather than simply retreat the
rook tried this move f5 going for a
little bit of play on the Kings side
instead now
don't really expect to see black go all
the way crazy in Kings Indian type of
pawn thrusts in this case at five's more
of a containing move a more of a
restricting move holding down the e4
square rather than going for four crazy
attacks yet so Bishop c3 was played
challenging blacks best minor piece on
the long diagonal rook d8 and now simply
F 3 is Hikaru's choice to gain control
of the e4 square mr. jobs back to e8 and
now we have Bishop a1 and we see the car
really taking his time here just kind of
maneuvering the pieces around to get
them in the best position possible to
play for a break now in this case of
course we do see black is not without
activity but like I said black is in
this case really waiting for white to
kind of make his play I'm waiting for
white to make his move and this is a
valid way to play chess it's just not a
very fun way to play chess but
practically it's it's a good thing to
know if you can't find your own plan in
the position it's best rather than do
nothing to play against your opponent's
plans and that's exactly what a nice
Giri is doing he's setting all of his
pieces on the best squares possible to
therefore breaks like efore in a five
Queeny seven now comes on the board
adding more pressure to this pawn bishop
g3 what's a carros choice eyeing a d6
pawn here Bishop f6 was played and the
players do a little bit of shuffling
Rick AC one brings her rook to the
center b6 helps solidify the black
structure perhaps it was even looking
for an optimistic a6 b5 someday but well
we'll see that never really happened and
now I want you with the white pieces to
come up with your plan to break through
find out where on the board you want to
break and how you want to achieve it
there is one main obvious break that you
can kind of play for and acara was
playing for in this game but there's
also one or two other ideas that can be
considered one or two other ideas so
what can you come up with
someone in the chat asks why not trade
with this Bishop on g7 well it's true
that this Bishop is active hikaru in
this case was looking to use his own
Bishop a little bit more effectively for
example pressuring d6 or maybe to
support another plan
I will say though it's a valid question
why did he come to see three in the
first place if he wasn't gonna trade
well if black was so naive as to take on
c3 we would have the nice be take c3 as
a recapture opening up the beef file and
giving us another Avenue of attack so
that's why neither player really traded
Cara was just kind of testing the waters
and black couldn't take cuz of B takes
c3 sorry sir Rick a 1 B 6 and now try
and come up with an idea here so
Thiago's says try to break it with E 4
that is the quote/unquote obvious break
I was talking about this is the main
plan in them no D you break with e4 and
then either you go for some King side
weaknesses with moves like a takes that
5 or you break through even further with
a move like a 5 trying to shake loose
the d6 pawn and get your own deep on
rolling vini venice'
really wants the move a 5 to be played
and he's letting us know so Brian has a
few different options
b4 h h5 & e 4 so h4 h5 e 4 and B 4 all
ideas he's coming up with here as well
as the move a 5 so you guys kind of have
it right here there's a few different
avenues of play one of course is in the
center but that is really the break that
black has lined his pieces up against
stopping you know he's got control of
the e-file he played f5 he's really
aimed at trying to prevent efore for as
long as possible so this break with h4
h5 might be a little bit ambitious it's
kind of tough to get this one working
practically it's tough to get these
moves through but it is a valid idea
against this type of structure and then
that third idea with b4 and eventually
even a5 is the break that a car went for
in this game and I think perhaps it's a
great idea
in the game
started with the move Bishop e1 this is
a great way to prepare the move before
and now Bishop g5 was played hitting III
so Bishop d2 to defend and any Giri
steps back with Bishop f6 Knight takes
t6 as a free pawn I don't think that
takes d6 was was ever quite winning
winning upon okay so now it's it's kind
of decision time
you can do a few things here you could
try and play more improving moves try
and find moves that still improve your
position even further you could break
with moves like rook e1 and E 4 you
could break with a move like B floor so
what do you guys think is it go time do
we go and break with b4 do we shift to
the e-file and break with E 4 or do we
still improve our position slowly steps
back why well black like I said doesn't
really have a lot to do here so black is
really waiting for for white to show his
hand and play one of these breaks so
black knows where he should divert his
pieces so black is kind of just passing
the time Tristan wants to play b4 now
b4 now
vlog 't wants to play a 5 I guess now
see the problem with a5 immediately is
really gonna be this b5 move this b5
move in and black I think is is winning
the game in fact b2 is hanging c4 is
coming and everything goes goes quite
wrong quite fast
still some improvements to be done
improve the rooks so you guys are
thinking like stock fish so stock fish
in fact just wanted to play a little bit
more slowly here and improve the
position further and then instead of
breaking on the queenside it actually
liked breaking with a floor instead so
one example line is to play move like b3
solidifying this Knight and getting this
pawn off of a square where it's attacked
play might continue with bishop g1 like
I said black really has nothing better
than to pass the time
King h1 is a nice improving move
stepping off of this diagonal for
example Bishop e6 will now move like
rook e1 Bishop back to g7 for example
and now the move like EE for this is how
the computer kind of wanted to handle
this position bring a rook to e1 and and
break with E 4 and play from here and
play might have continued with F takes
e4 and F takes e4 for example a rocket
step to the new newly opened file and a
move like Queen g3 and it's really just
gonna be a battle to see if white can
break through with e5 see if white can
find play on the Kings side and white
it's kind of keeping this idea in
reserve here not yet saying he's never
gonna do it but he's keeping it in
reserve while he plays in the center
now what karu decided to do is actually
really really strong as well this move
b4 however there is a problem with this
move there's only one problem and black
failed to find it in the game so see if
you can find the only way to equalize
here with black it's once again just
kind of a tactical issue with White's
plan
tactical issue with whites plan here
what can be played
what can be played okay
I'm not gonna spend too much time
because we are running out of it of
course I'm talking about the movie night
a six all of a sudden this b-pawn starts
to look a little bit weak and now if you
continue with b5 which is of course the
most natural way this was White's plan
you plant this pawn on b5 and you go for
this move
a5 to break down the Queen side well
night before comes on the board and all
of a sudden a lot of your pawns are
hanging this Queen is very much attacked
for example Queen b3 and black might
simply just take this pawn off the board
and now you're gonna be running into
some difficulties there are some
tactical tries here for example to move
efore it's gonna have to be replied to
by a move like Knight c7 you can throw
in a bishop d4 check if you want but
let's just say night c7 and now there
are these various checks but Queen e6
and and you're really only winning a
pawn back so Knight a 6 was a really
interesting tactical way for black to
stay in the game but it's pretty clear
that this is a little bit unnatural
opening up the diagonal in front of your
king like this just so happens
tactically it works for black so 96 was
missed however and instead Queen d7 was
played and now of course white simply
solidifies the advantage with this move
b5 and now black is quite simply much
worse here significantly worse now White
has all the time in the world to go for
this a5 plan and simply just just win
the game so let's see how a card did it
Queen f7 was played Bishop back to e1
now once again shifting over Queen e7
and rook b1 white needs to protect the
b-pawn before going for a 5 and now
black got a little bit antsy and played
the move f4 which once once again kind
of further makes whites play a little
bit easier
of course why it's responding to this
with the movie 4 and now you kind of get
the e4 break for free and E 5 is always
going to be a threat grass a little bit
better it's just passing once again with
a move like Bishop g7 although the move
a5 is really coming quickly here and you
have to be ready for it
so f4 instead
now e4 bishop d4 check king h1 rook b8
was black strife white takes this time
to finally take this bishop off the
board takes takes and now Queen f8 and
finally a five comes on the board and
this is kind of the death the death null
for a nice giri b takes a five was
played
but now the Queen gets active and all
the pawns fall apart here mmm Ric B 7 +
e5 is the key break for white it takes
and now this deep on wins the game night
a8 Knight takes e5 with a nice little
sacrifice if you were to capture on e5
well you get met with p7 and promotion
so Knight b6 instead d7 anyways rook d8
Ric d2 and Hikaru gets the rooks in the
game the Queen in the game and now a
niche Gary plays Queen takes d7 and
after the incredible move Knight takes
Queen
Anish Gary ended up resigning here oh
yeah and sorry there was a key line I
forgot to mention so of course in that
line I mentioned with Knight a6 the only
line for black to kind of equalize so
inside of Queen d7 if Knight a 6 and b5
night before you in fact you really
don't want to take off this night on
before exactly because of C takes before
and while you might be trying to regain
this pawn the bishop can actually step
to C 3 and this monster Bishop on a post
is is really gonna call us whites and
some serious headaches here but the
point of this game I wanted to show you
is this nice little opening advantage
that white god so white kind of took a
risk with this line with 92 if a nice
giri had managed to find this nice line
starting with Knight c7 and ending with
the tactical b5 breaking through and
then black would really be significantly
better
I believe but because he achieved the
slightly better version of a normal line
he got to get a permanent hold on the
position and when you get a hold like
this the way to play is to really try
and create threats on multiple places on
the
ward Nakamura made threats in the center
as well as the Queen side and the black
pieces couldn't really handle both this
idea of stretching and the black piece
is kind of thin is a really common one
and the other point of this lecture is
just take your time when your opponent
is just shuffling around waiting for you
to make a move then that's when you can
really try and improve your position to
the maximum before committing to a plan
a very impressive game by you Cara
Nakamura it kind of shows you how you
can play with this pawn on d5 yes
there's the central break but also
there's this play on the Queen side that
you can go for really instructive plans
they're from Hikaru all right we are
just about out of time so I will take
any last-minute questions you have and
then I think we will call the lecture
here and as Ben Simon has posted in the
chat there's another lecture happening
right after this one where I go over
some end games from the exact same
tournament some really fun end games for
the end game class okay well with that
in mind why don't we call it here once
again my name is Caleb Denby this has
been the road to 2002 thank you very
much for joining me and I will see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you